le bouquin de thierry séchan qui
s'appelle nos amis les chanteurs c'est a
fait du mal écoutez ce qui n'est pas la
main morte comédie florent pagny
prodigieux condensé de la connerie
humaine voire animal ah oui mais bon
pour arriver à vendre il faut y aller
faut y aller franco du repas maintenant
on se connaît pas il a dit aussi florent
aux anneaux fiché dans les oreilles ne
manque que la traîne et en tire le
rideau
pour y donner ça te dirait lui répondra
cialis et chant ben voilà
[Applaudissements]
jambon soir
des gens pas ni donc tu l'as pas
arranger la dans nos amis les amis des
chanteurs dans leur tour y est pour elle
vient dans nos amis les chanteurs le le
retour tu là ah je vends pas assez
discret juste dans le premier toit non
non ce que pour cela c'est parce que je
soupçonnais peut-être florent d'être
finalement un des plus courageux de tous
ces cons et là il est là alors est ce
que c'est le premier à la télévision
qu'ils acceptent de venir en a seulement
une télévision mais en radio partout je
cite une phrase de blake dans le second
qui est dit on opinions et le lâche tu
éviteras ouais effectivement je dis mon
opinion ça me coûte très cher ça me
coûte des projets etc
je le sais bien ouais mais ce qui m'a le
plus déçu c'est que ces chanteurs que je
connais pour certains ont tous refusé
alors que parfois ils avaient les moyens
intellectuels de me répondre
eh bien ils se sont tous des filets ils
se sont défilés et aucun l'art
effectivement sujet est vendu 300
exemplaires de mon livre je comprendrais
ouais mais effectivement et ça a très
bien marché
et comme le disait très justement et
intelligemment florent vraiment fallu
s'y révéler si tu le mets qui balancent
jeu il balance le métier dans deux
groupes un métier d'abord je dit le plus
grand bien de dien roda-gil par exemple
ça c'est bernard marc de méfiance et de
ton frère et de mon frère c'est mitigé
tant ce père renaud jeune fréquences
libérées moi-même et mitterrand donc
qu'est ce que tu as à lui dit rien
finalement il ya juste un détail que je
voulais dire c'est que marc lambron nous
dans l'équipe et chômage c'est une
triumph c'est pas une harley cd
bon alors on va passer parce que moi
j'ai lu ces deux bouquins mais j'ai pas
moi qui vais rapporter ce qu'il ya
dedans parce que tu es l'auteur un talus
mme patricia kaas présent tu dis quoi au
sujet de patrick lalime c'est un grand
mot je dis rien de plus agaçant pour moi
d'entendre par exemple que que c'est la
nouvelle piaf re piaf cocteau disait
madame piaf a du génie
wen moselle casse a du talent et puis on
parle plus bon moi ça ne me dérange pas
de voir des des sujets dans paris match
ou dans télé 7 jours la nouvelle marlene
dietrich la nvelle marilyn monroe
pourquoi pas la nouvelle isabella
rossellini aussi un petit croix marbre
bon j'ai rien contre mademoiselle k
c'est le vomi un peu en chantant mais
bon après tout il ya marc lavoine qui
vaut qui rote en chantant aussi donc
c'est non c'est pas une méchante fille
ya plus de gens méchants à dans tout le
monde est sympa tout le monde et c'est
vachement bien
elle va alors qu'ils allaient très
mignonne j'aurai beaucoup de mauvaise
grâce en dire du mal puisque j'ai un peu
écrit bah oui c'est ça en plus souvent
c'est des gens pour qui l'équipe
socialiste lui-même maintenant mais elle
s'annonce est une charmante jeune fille
je pense qu'elle est à peu près aussi
sexy que l'abbé pierre simone veil
réunis mais avant ça c'est parce qu'il
n'est pas faite que tu dis ça alors
l'âme c'est là là où c'est plus grave la
russie programme sait plus quand on
prend un ami un ami du président de la
république et des droits de l'homme qui
s'appelle yves simon qu'est ce que tu
dis aux sujets difficiles sinon c'est
pia parce que je ne dis rien je le site
unique l'un s'appelle yves simon no
comments et donc je cite yves simon qui
nous dit par exemple quand j'étais petit
et quand j'allais à l'école on apprenait
jamais mes leçons mais quand on
m'interrogeait je les savais déjà
ouais alors ça j'aime beaucoup ça voilà
il dit on lui demande c'est quoi votre
ambition c'est le goncourt la pléiade
l'académie il dit le goncourt c'est à
venir
la pléiade ce sera après ma mort et
l'académisme et songe pas encore si la
non de vanille tél et si j'ai une petite
fonction ce dur un peu nos stars cadre
décent un petit peu sur terre parce que
bon c'est bien les chanteurs on a besoin
sa compagne la ville et chansons et vous
savez bien que j'aime bien les chansons
j'ai écrit des biographies de chanteurs
aussi monsieur bras sont développés
comme tu développes dans tes bouquins je
suis désolé mais en rien qu'en regardant
mon truc a été obligé de te prendre
toutes les revues de presse et tout ce
que j'ai pu dire dans les canards pas
parce qu'elles ont des comptes étaient
discrets d'écouter la musique et
d'éviter russie avec le mec il quelque
part ils nous détestent ou bon c'est
aussi l'est pas c'est peut-être un
concept je suis je suis un faux méchant
et et on sait très bien que le faut mais
sans sont toujours des vrais gentils
alors que dans ton métier dans le nôtre
les vrais gentils qu'on voit constamment
sur nos écrans sont en fait très
régulièrement de terribles dégueulasse
alors je ricane un peu en racontant ses
dîners mondains auquel j'étais convié
avant de venir un artiste légiférer car
on joue au poker ensemble avec eux bruel
avec darmon avec l'inde honte à jouer au
poker avec brûle tout ça était oui on
prie beaucoup pour que tu fais
au début au début ça je prenais pas mal
je leur avais dit boillon jamais facile
j'avoue j'avais du mal à se rembourser
celui qui s'est le plus énervé et
s'extraire oui s'énerver il a dit à des
amis communs qui s'était retenue de me
faire un procès j'ai dit j'aurais
préféré qu'ils se retiennent de chanter
aimer cela dit bruel c'est pas le plus
nul non plus ils appuient des kouriles a
appris il a fait des progrès formidables
ils auraient pu le prendre avec un peu
d'humour et la prise sans le moindre
humour et c'est ce que je déplore ainsi
je vois pas en quoi c'est il ya deux
mois bon il aurait pu venir me parler à
la limite me casser la gueule rien le
tabac le voilà le voilà patrick
et ça vient d'où cette méchanceté ça
correspond à une tradition c'est simple
si on ne peut plus aujourd'hui écrire de
pamphlets si on ne peut plus balancer
maintenant je me dis pas ça moi toujours
en mesure la valeur d'un homme au nombre
de ses ennemis de dieu une phrase de
guitry extraordinaire qui dit si mes
ennemis savez ce que je pense d'eux il
me détestera encore plus j'en ai une
autre de henry de montherlant qui disait
se faire des amis est un souci de
commerçants se faire des ennemis une
occupation d'aristocrates c'est parfait
moi j'avais une de cocteau ces arrêts de
gens tu me fais mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]